il se passe quoi romain là y'a le feu de
poubelle ou quoi chronique goût selon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez été nombreux à me poser la
question dans les commentaires des
vidéos précédentes alors j'ai décidé d'y
répondre aujourd'hui
la cigarette électronique est elle
dangereuse alors pour commencer on va se
mettre d'accord sur les termes une
cigarette électronique ça produit pas de
la fumée mais de la vapeur pour ça elle
fait chauffer grâce à une résistance le
liquide qui est contenu dans son
réservoir et qu'on appelle un clyro misr
on peut l'utiliser pour plusieurs
raisons comme par exemple comme moyen de
substitution au tabac pour arrêter de
fumer
progressivement en gardant le geste et
la sensation de la fumée qu'on y nal
c'est pas con hein
marre de manger gras passé à l' irak
lettre p tfc liquide fromage et saveurs
poids de fumer une en blanc vous vous
ronger les ongles tester notre oncle
électronique consommer l'héroïne essayé
seringue et au bail dtc et grâce à notre
toit électronique
oui ça c'est vrai pour les ongles de
l'acadie se bat pour ça certains
liquides pour cigarettes électroniques
contiennent de la nicotine et d'autres
pas mais c'est pas tellement ça le plus
important parce qu'en réalité la
nicotine c'est ce qui rend accro mais
c'est pas ce qui rend malade à haute
dose
ça peut être nocif mais c'est vraiment
rien par rapport au reste la fumée de
cigarette celle avec du tabac
elle contient plus de 4000 substances
chimiques dont 90 sont toxiques et une
quarantaine cancérogènes qui rend malade
ce qui provoque des cancers c'est ce
qu'on appelle les goudrons mais ça dans
la vapeur de cigarettes électroniques
il y en a pas mais ça veut pas dire que
ça n'a aucun effet sur la santé
le problème vu qu'il ya deux problèmes
d'abord la cigarette électronique
elle n'a pas le même statut que les
chewing-gums à la nicotine les patchs et
sait pas tout ce qui est prescrit par un
médecin pour arrêter de fumer
du coup les liquides qu'elles
contiennent sont pas soumis aux mêmes
réglementations ni aux mêmes
surveillance concernant leurs
compositions qui nous amène directement
au deuxième problème on a à peu d'études
fiables sur leur réel toxicité et
surtout vu que c'est un dispositif
relativement récent on ne sait pas ce
que peut donner leur utilisation sur une
longue période
des chercheurs de l'université de
harvard ont mis en garde contre la
présence de diass et il dans certains
liquides de cigarettes électroniques le
dia cette île c'est un additif
alimentaire qui pose pas de problème
quand on le mange mais qui peut
entraîner une maladie respiratoire rare
qu'on appelle la bronchiolite
oblitérante quand on le respire c'est un
arôme qui est utilisé dans
l'agroalimentaire pour donner un goût
beurre ou de fromage non record ça pique
trop je vais vous prendre peur demi sel
on s'est rendu compte que ça rendait
malade après une multiplication de cas
de cette maladie respiratoire rare chez
les fabricants de pop corn qui respirait
toute la journée
cet arôme de beurre dans le cas des
cigarettes électroniques le dias et il
est utilisé notamment pour la
fabrication des liquides saveurs bonbons
ou saveurs gâteau les normes françaises
recommandent de ne pas les utiliser donc
normalement il y en a pas dans les
liquides madeinfrance normalement parce
que les normes les fabricants ne sont
pas obligés de les suivre
toujours en 2015 le new england journal
of medicine a publié une étude qui
affirmait que la cigarette électronique
étaient cinq à quinze fois plus
cancérogènes que le tabac en cause une
substance appelée le formaldéhyde qu'ils
seraient libérés quand on surchauffe le
liquide
mais cette étude a été très controversé
les experts ont estimé que pour
atteindre de tels chiffres il faudrait
tellement chauffer le liquide que ça
deviendrait impossible de le voter
attention chez les femmes enceintes
aussi la vapeur contient des substances
qui pourraient présenter un risque pour
le développement du foetus notamment au
niveau respiratoire là encore on parle
d' études menées sur un petit nombre de
souris c'est pas suffisant pour être sûr
mais c'est suffisant pour être prudent
et pour continuer les recherches
les premières études menées sur les
voies respiratoires des vapoteurs semble
aussi indiqué des conséquences négatives
au niveau immunitaire
prudence aussi chez les asthmatiques bon
de base
fumer quand on est asthmatique c'est pas
une bonne idée bon ça c'est pour essayer
d'arrêter pour ça
anus électronique dtc l'essayer c'est
l'adopter bon ça c'est pour l'étape
auteurs mais pour ceux qui sont autour
est-ce que c'est dangereux une étude
norvégienne a montré que le taux de
nicotine dans le sang de l'entourage
d'eva potter était aussi élevé qu'avec
des cigarettes classiques mais comme on
l'a vu la nicotine la fac et dangereux
et comme la vapeur des cigarettes
électroniques ne contient pas de
substances vraiment dangereuse bon dans
le doute
la loi française elle interdit la vente
aux mineurs et elle interdit aussi de
vapoter dans les transports en commun
sur les lieux de travail fermés et dans
les établissements accueillant des
mineurs dans tous les autres lieux
publics comme les bars ou les restos par
exemple c'est au propriétaire de décider
s'il interdit ou pas au-delà des risques
pour la santé ce qui inquiète les
professionnels c'est que les gens
recommencent à vapoter là où c'est
interdit de fumer
les interdictions ça commence à peine à
rentrer dans les moeurs alors bon qui
inquiète aussi c'est que la cigarette
électronique se démocratise et devienne
une porte d'entrée dans le tabac au lieu
d'être une porte de sortie
donc on peut pas vraiment dire que la
cigarette électronique est sans danger
pour celui qui va pote ni même pour son
entourage
par contre ce qu'on peut dire à coup sûr
c'est que les effets négatifs du tabac
sur la santé
là il ya vraiment pas de doute et qui
sont assez clairement bien plus méchant
que ceux de la cigarette électronique
il n'y a pas d'études scientifiques qui
démontrent de façon certaine
l'efficacité de la cigarette
électronique au moyen d'arrêter de fumer
du tabac du gard rien ne montre que ça
marche mieux que les autres méthodes
mais on sait que c'est un outil efficace
pour réduire sa consommation de tabac et
rien que ça c'est déjà pas mal
si la cigarette électronique c'est un
moyen de diminuer sa consommation de
tabac voire de l'arrêter c'est tout
bénef
il n'y a pas trop besoin de réfléchir
par contre si c'est pour continuer de
cloper et se taper un petit shoot de
nicotine house est interdit de fumer
bof bon vous allez les infos maintenant
vous en faites ce que vous voulez voilà
dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo en attendant mettez vous bien et
surtout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]